Who would play me in the movie of my life? Shia LaBeouf. I like how Connor had no hesitation. Connor just knew. Welcome to ADSP The the podcast, episode 55, recorded on December 5th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we live code a solution to a leak code problem in C++. This is part one of a two-part episode where, in next week's episode, we'll solve the same problem, but in BQM. Nice shorts, by the way. Those are are nice shorts i'm admiring your shorts i'm
谁会在我的人生电影里扮演我？希亚·拉博夫。我喜欢康纳毫无犹豫的样子。康纳直接就知道了。欢迎来到 ADSP The 播客，第 55 期，录制于 2021 年 12 月 5 日。我叫康纳，今天我的联合主持是布莱斯，我们在 C++ 中现场编写了一个 LeetCode 问题的解决方案。这是两集节目的第一部分，在下周的节目中，我们将用 BQN 解决同一个问题。话说回来，你的短裤挺好看的。那些短裤挺好看的，我在欣赏你的短裤，我
wearing shorts yeah i was admiring your shorts i like them they're a good color yeah lululemon baby yeah although it's winter why are you wearing shorts oh it's toasty in my apartment. I haven't even turned the heater on. What is toasty? And if you give it to me in Celsius, I'm not going to be amused. I don't know. I don't know how warm it is in my apartment. I have no idea. But not cold enough to require me wearing pants. Are we recording?
穿着短裤，对，我刚刚在欣赏你的短裤，我挺喜欢的，颜色不错，对，Lululemon 的宝贝，对，虽然现在是冬天，你为什么要穿短裤？哦，我的公寓里很暖和。我甚至都没开暖气。什么叫暖和？如果你用摄氏度来告诉我，我可不会觉得好笑。我不知道。我不知道我公寓里有多暖和。我完全不知道。但还没冷到需要我穿裤子的地步。我们在录音吗？
Are we good to go? Of course I'm recording. All right. Here we go, pants. Are we recording? Is this, are we good? Are we good to go? Of course I'm recording. All right. Here we go, Bryce. Are you ready? I also, yeah. Are you ready? In celebration.
我们准备好了吗？我当然在录音了。好了。我们开始吧，裤子。我们在录音吗？这个，我们好了吗？我们准备好了吗？我当然在录音了。好了。我们开始吧，布莱斯。你准备好了吗？我也，对。你准备好了吗？为了庆祝。
So I got too thirsty because Bryce was like 17 minutes late. I was savoring a cupcake. I sent you a polite message informing you that I was savoring a cupcake. That's true. I'm not sure how that took 17 minutes, but I had to open my grapefruit bubbly that I was waiting. But because we're celebrating, because we're celebrating, Bryce, I got another bubbly. And this one's lime. Here we go, folks.
所以我变得太渴了，因为布莱斯迟到了大约 17 分钟。我正在细细品尝一个纸杯蛋糕。我发了一条礼貌的信息告诉你我正在品尝一个纸杯蛋糕。确实如此。我不确定这怎么就花了 17 分钟，但我不得不打开我一直等着喝的葡萄柚气泡水。但因为我们在庆祝，因为我们在庆祝，布莱斯，我又拿了一罐气泡水。这一罐是青柠味的。各位，我们开始吧。
Here we go. Episode, what episode is this? This is episode, like, 56. Woo! Right there, baby. Right there. So a couple things. One, clearly you've never savored a cupcake before. I'll have to change that.
我们开始吧。节目，这是第几期？这是第几期，大概第 56 期。呜呼！就是这样，宝贝。就是这样。所以有几件事。第一，很显然你以前从来没有品尝过纸杯蛋糕。我得改变这一点。
Two, what are we celebrating? Oh, yeah. So remember two episodes ago, I said, oh, I'm not going to get to update the listener on how my 10K race goes because we're going to be talking to the Kneeblers. But I didn't realize that was next weekend. So we're recording today. And I did a 10K in Toronto yesterday and a 10K in Vancouver seven days ago. And I smashed my personal record by two minutes. Previously it was 37 23 and it is now 35 29.
第二，我们在庆祝什么？哦，对。所以还记得两期前，我说过，哦，我没法向听众更新我的 10 公里赛跑情况了，因为我们要和尼布勒一家聊天。但我没意识到那是下周末。所以我们今天录音。我昨天在多伦多跑了 10 公里，七天前在温哥华跑了 10 公里。我把我的个人纪录打破了两分钟。以前是 37 分 23 秒，现在是 35 分 29 秒。
Wow. That is a pretty good 10 K time folks. Let me tell you it's a, yep, it's good. And, I was beat by a 14 year old. That doesn't feel,
哇。各位，这确实是一个相当不错的 10 公里成绩。让我告诉你们，这是一个，是的，很不错。而且，我被一个 14 岁的小孩打败了。这感觉不大行，
um, congrats to Steph. Uh uh i got to admit i was running alongside him in second place like tied for second from like kilometer two and a half to five and i thought this kid's running way too fast he's gonna gas out and then at the five kilometer mark i'm the one that is starting to gas out and then he just like runs away and I'm like I gotta reassess where I'm at someone told me later I should have got his autograph because he's probably gonna end up in like the Olympics or something later on
呃，恭喜斯蒂芬。呃，我得承认，从大约两公里半到五公里，我和他并肩跑在第二位，并列第二，当时我想这孩子跑得太快了，他会体力耗尽的，然后在五公里处，轮到我开始体力耗尽了，然后他就直接跑开了，我就想我得重新评估一下我的状况了，后来有人告诉我我本该找他要个签名，因为他以后可能会进奥运会什么的，
which is a good point so wait did you finish second in this 10k that 10k that was in Vancouver I finished third because yeah the 14 year old beat me. I haven't ridden my bike.
这倒是个好主意。等等，你在这次 10 公里比赛中获得了第二名吗？温哥华的那场 10 公里比赛，我得了第三名，因为是的，那个 14 岁的小孩击败了我。我没有骑自行车。
I mean, I spin in the gym, but I haven't ridden my bike since October because it's cold. But good news. Something, like, happened when I came back from Florida. My, like, cold adaptivity kicked in. And, like, I've been, like, walking around around in like, you know, a t-shirt the past few days. And I've been like, you know what? I, I, now I remember what it was like to be cold in new England as a kid. And I kind of like it. It's not that bad. So something just, something just kicked in. No to the cold. We don't like the cold. No, I do like the cold. I do like the cold. It just took me a little while to get used to the cold and remember that I did like it.
我的意思是，我在健身房踩动感单车，但我自 10 月以来就没骑过自行车了，因为天气很冷。但好消息是。有些事情，就像我从佛罗里达回来时发生了变化。我的那种抗寒适应能力被激活了，然后，在过去的几天里，我一直像这样穿着 T 恤走来走去。我一直在想，你知道吗，我，我，现在我记起小时候在新英格兰挨冻是什么感觉了。我其实还挺喜欢的。没那么糟糕。所以有什么东西，有什么东西刚刚被激活了。对寒冷说不。我们不喜欢寒冷。不，我确实喜欢寒冷。我确实喜欢寒冷。只是花了我一点时间来适应寒冷并记起我是喜欢它的。
Oh, I got my COVID booster today. Oh, how are you feeling? I'm feeling fine thus far. My arm's a little bit sore. I imagine I'm going to feel not as good tomorrow. Yeah. But what about you? You got a new booster yet?
哦，我今天打了我的新冠疫苗加强针。哦，你感觉怎么样？到目前为止我感觉很好。我的胳膊有点酸。我想我明天感觉就不会这么好了。是的。但你呢？你打过新的加强针了吗？
Are they giving out boosters in Canada? I know that my grandmother got her booster in Vancouver months ago at least. So I know that they are giving them out, but definitely I don't think it's, you know, white dudes in their 30s are allowed to get them yet. At least I haven't heard anything about it. And I would have heard because I've been first through the door every opportunity when they've opened it up for me to get it. Well, you should move on
加拿大在分发加强针吗？我知道我奶奶几个月前至少在温哥华接种了她的加强针。所以我知道他们正在分发，但毫无疑问我认为这，你知道的，三十多岁的白人男子还不被允许接种。至少我没有听到任何相关的消息。而且我本该听说的，因为每当他们为我开放接种机会时，我总是第一个冲进门的人。好吧，你应该搬到
down to move on down to america and you can get yourself a covid booster um yeah we'll think about it i mean i've got a race in austin texas uh you're going to austin texas i know so that's the thing i'm not sure i'm going because of omicron um and it's on January 23rd. We're recording this. Today is what? The December 5th. So depending on how things unfold. Connor, it's like 2022.
美国来，然后你就能给自己打一针新冠加强针了，呃，是的，我们会考虑的。我的意思是，我在得克萨斯州奥斯汀有一场比赛，呃，你要去得克萨斯州奥斯汀？我知道，这就是问题所在，因为奥密克戎的缘故，我不确定我是否要去，而且比赛是在 1 月 23 日。我们在录制这个。今天是几号？12 月 5 日。所以这取决于事情将如何发展。康纳，这就像是 2022 年了。
Like, has that hit you yet? What does that mean? Like, it's like 2022. Like, that's the year that it basically is. I mean, that is one plus 2021. You're not understanding what I'm saying. Break it down for me, Bryce. Break it down for me.
就像是，这个概念对你有什么实感吗？这是什么意思？就像是 2022 年了。就像，基本上就是那个年份。我的意思是，那是 1+2021。你没懂我的意思。给我剖析一下，布莱斯。给我剖析一下。
In my mind, last year was like 2011. 2011? Yeah. Like where did like the past 10 years go? We're like old men now. 2011 feels like, doesn't feel like yesterday. It feels like three decades ago for me. Yeah, it is starting to feel that way.
在我的脑海里，去年就像是 2011 年。2011 年？是的。过去的 10 年都去哪儿了？我们现在就像老头子一样。2011 年感觉，倒不觉得像昨天。对年代来说感觉像三十年前了。是的，开始有那种感觉了。
Like, in 2011, I guess it depends on what month you want to choose. But, like, I was in, like, halfway through university. I had moved to Toronto for the first time and was working for an insurance company called John Hancock, which is a subsidy at the time it was a subsidiary of Manulife. I mean, that's what I did for eight months of that year. And 2011, that was my,
就像，在 2011 年，我想这取决于你想选择哪个月。但是，就像，我当时在，大约是大学过半。我第一次搬到多伦多，并在一家名为约翰·汉考克的保险公司工作，当时它是宏利金融的一个子公司。我的意思是，那是我那一年八个月的工作经历。2011 年，那是我的，
that was my second, that was my first year at LSU. So I had just come back from my first time at the supercomputing conference, which was in Seattle. And that was like the third tech conference I went to. I'd already been to... Fun fact, most people think that the first conference that I went to is BoostCon 2011, because I talk about how it was such a life-changing experience for me. But actually, I went to the Linux Foundation Collaboration Summit, or it was something with that sort of title, in San Francisco, like a month before that, to talk about
那是我的第二，那是我在路易斯安那州立大学的第一年。所以我刚从我第一次参加的超级计算大会回来，那是在西雅图。那是我去的第三个技术会议。我已经去过了……有趣的是，大多数人认为我去的第一个会议是 2011 年的 BoostCon，因为我经常说那是如何改变我一生经历的。但实际上，在那之前大约一个月，我去旧金山参加了 Linux 基金会协作峰会，或者大概是这个名字的会议，去谈论
compiling the Linux kernel with Clang and LLVM. And I met Marshall Clow at the Linux Foundation Summit thing. And then I went to BoostCon 2011. And I also saw Marshall Clow. And they were like two very different communities. So I was just like, oh, this guy just goes to every tech conference. What was the first conference that you spoke at? That Linux Foundation. God, I won't remember what the name is.
用 Clang 和 LLVM 编译 Linux 内核。我在 Linux 基金会峰会上遇到了马歇尔·克劳。然后我去了 2011 年的 BoostCon。我也见到了马歇尔·克劳。它们是两个截然不同的社群。所以我当时就想，哦，这家伙简直参加了每一个技术会议。你演讲的第一场会议是什么？那个 Linux 基金会。天哪，我不记得名字是什么了。
But that Linux Foundation Collaboration Summit was the first conference I spoke at. In 2011? Yeah. It was the first conference I attended, the first one I spoke at, because they wanted me to talk about compiling Linux with LLVM. That's crazy. Hang on. But you spoke at the first conference that you went to.
但那个 Linux 基金会协作峰会是我进行演讲的第一场会议。在 2011 年？是的。那是我参加的第一场会议，也是我演讲的第一场会议，因为他们想让我谈谈用 LLVM 编译 Linux。这太疯狂了。等等。但你在你去的第一个会议上就进行了演讲。
Yeah, but that's what I'm saying is that like, so 10 years ago for you, you were sort of already in the C++ community. I was in a whole different education path slash career path. I didn't speak or go to a tech conference until 2019, which was two years ago. know i remember i was there poking you with a stick making you speak it's just crazy to think that of the last decade like 80 of it wasn't doing any of the stuff but like you skip back a decade and you were you were starting that like it's it's uh we do share a lot you know we've mentioned this a couple times about our first languages ti basic and quasi dropping out i mean you actually did drop out or kick got kicked out and i kind of got kicked anyways there's a lot of similarities but when you look when you compare the last decade and where we were at that's totally different um yeah i was not expecting
对，但我想说的是，对你来说 10 年前，你某种程度上就已经在 C++ 社区里了。我当时处于一条完全不同的教育路径兼职业路径上。直到 2019 年我才在一个技术会议上发言或参加技术会议，那已经是两年前了。我知道，我记得我在那里用棍子戳你，逼你发言。回想过去十年，其中 80% 的时间根本没做过这些事，而你回溯一个十年，你却在刚开始做这些，这真是太疯狂了，我们确实有很多共同点，你知道的，我们之前提到过几次我们的第一门语言是 TI BASIC 和曾经辍学，我的意思是，你实际上确实辍学了或被开除了，而我某种程度上也算是被开除了，无论如何，有很多相似之处，但当你审视，当你比较过去十年以及我们当时所在的地方时，那是完全不同的，嗯，是的，我没想到
you to say oh i like for some reason i thought you were gonna say oh my first time i spoke was like at you know cpp con 2015 or 16 or something because i feel like that's the first youtube talk that i've seen no like that goes that far back there is somewhere a recording of the first talk that i gave at boost con not the first not the talk i gave at the the linux foundation thing um there is a recording of that talk that i gave it boost con somewhere um but like very well hidden because it was bad i stayed up i i was up until 4 a.m the night before it was an 8 a.m talk because i was still making slides and i i recall i made a bunch of really bad star wars references yeah that was this on youtube is this on youtube it might be on youtube all right
你会说，哦，我，不知为什么我以为你会说，哦，我第一次演讲是在，你知道的，2015 或 2016 年的 CppCon 之类的，因为我觉得那是你看过的最早的 YouTube 演讲，没有，那种可以追溯到很久以前的演讲，在某处有我当年在 BoostCon 演讲的录音，不是我在那个 Linux 基金会活动上的演讲，我在 BoostCon 上演讲的录音在某处的某个地方，但被藏得很好，因为那太糟糕了。我前一天晚上熬到了凌晨 4 点，因为那是一个早上 8 点的演讲，我当时还在做幻灯片，我记得我做了一堆非常糟糕的《星球大战》梗。是的，这在 YouTube 上吗？这在 YouTube 上吗？它可能在 YouTube 上，好吧。
and what year is this the year is this boost con 2011 i was talking about um uh boost spirit u-tree um which was a an ast data type for boost spirit which is a parser framework which is the first not not the first thing i worked on in boost but a project that i rapidly gravitated towards um because when i my first exposure to boost was i was using it for this you know as we've discussed before i you know started learning to program to write this game um and then i got you know I learned about Boost because I was using it for this game project. And I very quickly got sidetracked working on, you know, Boost. The thing that I first, my first exposure to Boost was Boost String Algorithms Split.
这是哪一年？这是 2011 年的 BoostCon。我当时在谈论，呃，Boost Spirit u-tree，它是 Boost Spirit 的一个 AST 数据类型，而 Boost Spirit 是一个解析器框架，这不是我在 Boost 中做的第一件事，而是一个我迅速被吸引过去的专案，因为当我，我最早接触 Boost 是因为我正在用它来做这个，正如我们之前讨论过的，我（你知道的）开始学习编程来写这个游戏，然后我得到了（你知道的），我了解到 Boost 是因为我正在将它用于这个游戏专案。我很快就分心去致力于，你知道的，Boost。我最早接触 Boost 的东西是 Boost String Algorithms Split。
I don't remember why I needed it, but it was a text-based game that I was working on. They're called MUDs, Multi dungeons or dimensions and uh i think i was using boost string algos split to do some tokenization of input lines um and there was some bug in it and i like reported the bug and like sent a patch to fix the bug um but then i think from there somebody must have told me to use Boost Spirit instead for my parsing needs. And that's sort of how I got from submitting this bug about Boost Format, while he's known these days as being the guy who runs the HPX project, the Parallel Runtime, he was also one of the maintainers and founders of Boost Spirit. And so that's how we initially connected was that I was contributing to Boost Spirit. And then that's, you know, I randomly asked him for a job on IRC having never met him. And that's when he said, you should fly on down to Louisiana.
我不记得我为什么需要它了，但那是我正在开发的一个基于文本的游戏。它们被称为 MUD，即多用户地牢或空间，呃，我想我当时在使用 Boost string algos split 来对输入行进行一些词法标记化，其中有一些错误，我报告了这个错误，并发送了一个补丁来修复这个错误，但随后我想从那时起，某人一定告诉过我改用 Boost Spirit 来满足我的解析需求。这就是我如何从提交这个关于 Boost Format 的错误开始走到这一步的——他如今以运营 HPX 项目（即并行运行时）的人而闻名，他也是 Boost Spirit 的维护者和创始人之一。所以我们最初就是这样建立联系的，即我一直在为 Boost Spirit 做贡献。然后这就是，你知道的，我在 IRC 上随口向他讨要了一份工作，在此之前从未见过他。然后他当时说，你应该飞到路易斯安那州来。
Yeah. Damn, man, you got started so early. It was really weird. I like started learning C++ and then three months later I was like, I had like commit access to boost and then three months after that i was um you know i was the the the release um manager for one of the boost sphere releases and then like three months after that i was speaking at boost con and then three months after that i was at lsu and three months after that hartman and i were starting our own research group and i have like more responsibilities than than i uh i i
是啊。天哪，老兄，你起步太早了。这真的很诡异。我开始学习 C++，然后三个月后，我就像，我有了 Boost 的提交权限，再过三个月，嗯，我成了某个 Boost Spirit 发行版的发布经理，然后又过了三个月，我在 BoostCon 上演讲，然后又过三个月，我在路易斯安那州立大学，再过三个月，哈特曼和我开始创办我们自己的研究小组，我的责任比我作为一个 19 或 20 岁大学辍学生
should have had as a 19 or 20 year old college dropout it was a very it was a very crazy period of my life they should make a movie i'd watch it i i i would watch it too who would who would play me in the movie of my life shia labeouf i like how connor had no hesitation connor just knew i just it's it's funny too because like I did not have that pre-prepared but like it's if we're playing like the young version though unfortunately he's a bit too old now but like no no but like young
本该拥有的还要多。那是我人生中非常疯狂的一段时期。他们应该拍一部电影，我会看的。我，我也会看。谁会在我的人生电影里扮演我？希亚·拉博夫。我喜欢康纳毫无犹豫的样子。康纳直接就知道了。我只是觉得，这也挺搞笑的，因为我并没有提前准备好，但如果是让我们扮演年轻的版本的话，虽然不幸的是他现在有点太老了，但，不，不，就像年轻的
Shia LaBeouf would be perfect yeah he would absolutely be perfect I don't know why that came to mind so quickly who would play you? I don't know a young Tom Cruise Came to mind so quickly. Who are you? Hmm. I don't know. A young Tom Cruise?
希亚·拉博夫会是完美的，是的，他绝对会是完美的。我不知道为什么这个名字会这么快浮现在脑海里。谁会扮演你？我不知道。年轻的汤姆·克鲁斯。这么快就浮现在脑海里了。你是谁？嗯。我不知道。年轻的汤姆·克鲁斯？
I was thinking Brad Pitt. I was thinking Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt? Tom Cruise? Yeah. No. I'm not. That's generous of you, Bryce. You are a very good looking individual.
我当时在想布拉德·皮特。我当时在想布拉德·皮特。布拉德·皮特？汤姆·克鲁斯？是的。不。我不是。你太慷慨了，布拉德。你是一个长相非常好看的人。
I mean, that's. I mean, you said that's very generous of you but you but you led with tom cruise so uh that's only because there was a girl in university that called me tom because she said i look like tom cruise oh speak speaking of girls speaking of girls all right well we should probably we should probably uh get to the podcast. We can do something real brief to round out our talking about whatever we were talking about by doing another real brief leet code in BQN if you want. It's a very short solution, and I was so in love with it. I've been on a tear lately.
我的意思是，那是。我的意思是，你说这对我太慷慨了，但你首先提到了汤姆·克鲁斯，所以，那只是因为大学里有个女孩叫我汤姆，因为她说我看起来像汤姆·克鲁斯。哦，说到女孩，说到女孩，好吧，我们大概应该，我们大概应该，呃，开始播客了。我们可以做一些非常简短的事情来结束我们对无论什么的讨论，如果你愿意的话，可以在 BQN 中再做一个非常简短的 LeetCode。这是一个非常短的解决方案，我太喜欢它了。我最近势头正猛。
But let me share screens first. And actually, maybe we'll do it. We'll see how quickly we can do this. What is it? 637. We probably chatted for 15 minutes. Let's see if we can solve this in both C++. I'll type.
但让我先共享屏幕。实际上，也许我们会做。我们会看看我们能以多快的速度完成这个。几点了？6 点 37 分。我们大概聊了 15 分钟。让我们看看我们是否可以用 C++ 两个都解决。我来打字。
You tell me what to type. And Godbolt. Oh, yeah. So here's the problem. Yeah. Find, or do you want to read it? I'll read it. Find target indices after sorting array. You're given a zero index integer, array nums, and a target element, target. A target index is an index.
你告诉我打什么。还有 Godbolt。哦，对。所以问题是这样的。是的。寻找排序数组后的目标索引。给你一个从零开始索引的整数数组 nums 和一个目标元素 target。目标索引是一个索引。
Oh, OK. A target index is an index i such that the index of your array nums is equal to the target. And the question asks you to return a list of the target indices of your array nums after sorting nums in non-decreasing order. And if there's no target indices, just return an empty list. So for example, if your list is 1, 2, 5, 2, 3, and your target is 2, after sorting your array nums, it would be 1, 2, 2, 3, 5.
哦，好的。目标索引是一个索引 i，使得你的数组 nums 的索引等于目标。问题要求你返回一个列表，包含在将 nums 按非递减顺序排序后，你的数组 nums 的目标索引。如果没有目标索引，则只返回一个空列表。例如，如果你的列表是 1, 2, 5, 2, 3，你的目标是 2，在对你的数组 nums 进行排序后，它将是 1, 2, 2, 3, 5。
And then you just need to return all the indices that are equal to your target value. So because two is your target value, that corresponds to index one and index two. All right. I understand. You're only ever given one target. Correct. One target. And so the second example is the same list. One, two, five, two, three. Your target now is three. And if you sort this once again, it's one, two, two, three, 3. Your target now is 3. And if you sort this, once again, it's 1, 2, 2, 3, 5. And the 3 is in index 3. So that's your answer. The third example is target equal to 5, same list. If you sort it, 5 is going to be the last number in the list, which will be equal to index 4. And then if your target is 4, that value doesn't show up in 1 2 5 2 3 so you end up with
然后你只需要返回所有等于你的目标值的索引。所以因为二你的目标值，这对应于索引一和索引二。好的。我明白了。你永远只会得到一个目标吗？没错。一个目标。所以第二个例子是相同的列表。1, 2, 5, 2, 3。你现在的目标是 3。如果你再次排序这个，它是 1, 2, 2, 3, 3。你的目标现在是 3。如果你对这个排序，再次它是 1, 2, 2, 3, 5。3 在索引 3。所以这就是你的答案。第三个例子是目标等于 5，相同的列表。如果你对它排序，5 将是列表中的最后一个数字，它将等于索引 4。然后如果你的目标是 4，该值不会出现在 1 2 5 2 3 中，所以你最后得到的是
an empty list let's head over to so let's copy let's copy or actually we can do it straight in here what are we talking about what are we talking about um let's zoom in and change this to auto um so we've got target indices as a function. It takes a vector of ints. Why is there a class here? I'm so confused. That's just the way that it works for leet code. That should be a function.
一个空列表。让我们前往，所以让我们复制，让我们复制，或者实际上我们可以直接在这里做。我们在说什么？我们在说什么？让我们放大并将此更改为 auto。所以我们有一个作为函数的 target indices。它接受一个由 int 组成的 vector。为什么这里有一个类？我太糊涂了。这只是 LeetCode 的运作方式。那应该是一个函数。
And actually. Who do I call about that? The leet code folks. That's some Java nonsense. How do you want to solve this, man? What do you want to do? Well, so, I mean,
实际上。我该给谁打电话反映这个？LeetCode 的人。那是某些 Java 的无稽之谈。老兄，你想怎么解决这个？你想做什么？嗯，所以，我的第一反应是
my first thought is that we want to sort the array, but I was actually, I was actually wondering whether we could, I wonder if they have, I wonder if they have C++20. What do you think? So, I mean, obviously we have to sort the array, but I'm just wondering whether we can somehow...
我们想要对数组进行排序，但我实际上，我实际上在想我们是否可以，我想知道他们是否有，我想知道他们是否有 C++20。你觉得呢？所以，我的意思是，显然我们必须对数组进行排序，但我只是在想我们是否可以某种程度上……
We have to perform the work that would be involved in sorting the array, but I wonder whether calling std sort is actually the best way to do this. Connor tried calling std ranges sort um and discovered that leak code yeah i think they only have c++ 17 um have c++ 20 which is not shocking to me given that the like leak code structure for a problem is like very clearly like 90s object-oriented C++. No offense to anybody that works at LeetCode, but a little bit of offense was intended. So we've sorted our array.
我们必须执行对数组进行排序所涉及的工作，但我怀疑调用 std sort 实际上是不是解决这个问题的最好方法。康纳尝试调用 std ranges sort，然后发现 LeetCode，是的，我想他们只有 C++17。有 C++20 吗？这对我来说并不奇怪，考虑到 LeetCode 问题的结构非常明显就像是 90 年代面向对象的 C++。对在 LeetCode 工作的人没有任何冒犯之意，但还是带有一点冒犯的意图。所以我们已经对数组进行了排序。
What do we want to do next? Go back up to the problem. Actually, you know what? We definitely... We're switching to Gobbolt because I want C++20. I ain't messing around. So you want to find, I mean, call std find. Why do we need st find the first element in the sorted list that matches
接下来我们想做什么？回到问题。事实上，你知道吗？我们绝对……我们要切换到 Godbolt，因为我想要 C++20。我可不瞎胡闹。所以你想找，我的意思是，调用 std find。为什么我们需要 std find 排序列表中匹配
the target. And what we really need is like an equal range, something like that. It's not an algorithm. It is an algorithm. There we go. See, I know stuff.
目标的第一个元素。而我们真正需要的是类似 equal range 的东西，诸如此类。这不是一个算法。它是一个算法。这就对了。你看，我懂东西。
I guess we need to do include range. Yeah, forget find. We should just be calling equal range, right? Which is not actually a C++20 thing. Equal range was an algorithm pre-C++20, before there was a notion of ranges in the language. Or the notion of ranges in the language that we currently have. But equal range, you give it a pair of iterators and a value, and it returns you a pair of iterators,
我想我们需要 include ranges。是的，忘掉 find 吧。我们应该直接调用 equal range，对吧？这实际上并不是 C++20 的东西。Equal range 在 C++20 之前就是一个算法，在语言中出现 ranges 的概念之前。或者说在我们目前拥有的语言中对 ranges 的概念出现之前。但对于 equal range，你给它一对迭代器和一个值，它会返回给你一对迭代器，
which is all the elements that are equal to the value, and it expects that the input sequence is partially ordered with respect to the value, which is going to be the case here because we've done this sort. Wait, okay, hang on, hang on, hang on. We only need to sort until, I'm not convinced that we need to sort the entire array, right? Because we only need to sort up until we've gotten to the target that we're looking for.
这就是所有等于该值的元素，并且它期望输入序列相对于该值是部分有序的，由于我们已经完成了排序，这里情况正是如此。等等，好吧，等等，等等，等等。我们只需要排序直到，我不确信我们需要对整个数组进行排序，对吧？因为我们只需要排序直到我们找到我们正在寻找的目标。
And I'm wondering if there's some clever sorting algorithm that lets us only sort. So what is this going to return? This is going to return us probably a pair. A pair, yeah, a pair. Whoa, whoa, whoa, what are you doing? Shouldn't we be destructuring that? They're going to be iterators, but yeah, we probably can do that.
我在想是不是有什么聪明的排序算法能让我们只进行部分排序。所以这个会返回什么？这个可能会返回给我们一个 pair。一个 pair，是的，一个 pair。哇，哇，哇，你在干什么？我们不应该解构它吗？它们将是迭代器，但是的，我们大概可以做到这一点。
So let's do first. Okay, so we have the iter iterators and it wants us to return the indices well then we're going to take those iterators those are going to be random access iterators so we can just we can just
所以我们来做 first。好的，所以我们有了迭代器，它希望我们返回索引，嗯，然后我们将采用这些迭代器，那些将是随机访问迭代器，所以我们就可以
we can just do some some pointer arithmetic so yeah we have currently we have we can just do some pointer arithmetic. So yeah, currently we have std colon colon ranges colon colon sort. And then we've got structured bindings, f comma l equals std colon colon ranges colon colon equal range. And if we dereference both f and l, it gives us the values 2 and 3. And so now we just need to get the indices which correspond to basically what?
我们就可以做一些指针算术。所以，是的，目前我们有。我们可以做一些指针算术。所以，是的，目前我们有 std colon colon ranges colon colon sort。然后我们有结构化绑定，f comma l 等于 std colon colon ranges colon colon equal range。如果我们对 f 和 l 都解引用，它会给我们值 2 和 3。所以现在我们只需要获取与基本上什么相对应的索引？
Wait, why is it giving us two? Yeah, so what we need to do is we need to just do some iterator arithmetic here. Yeah, yeah, sure. You can call distance. Sure. Oh, you just want to figure out like how many there are. Sure. Fine. That's okay. I have no objection with that. Oh, actually we can use IOTA here. That was what I was thinking.
等等，为什么它给我们 2？是的，所以我们需要做的是，我们只需要在这里做一些迭代器算术。对，对，当然。你可以调用 distance。当然。哦，你只是想弄清楚有多少个。当然。好的。我对此没有异议。哦，实际上我们可以在这里使用 iota。这就是我当时想的。
Yeah, because if the answer is more than one element, then they're going to be consecutive. So we just need to figure out the starting value for iota, which is going to be the distance from the beginning of the input to that first element that we found and we'll want iota for the size of the output is going to be
是的，因为如果答案不止一个元素，那么它们将是连续的。所以我们只需要弄清楚 iota 的起始值，这将是从输入开头到我们找到的第一个元素的距离，并且我们希望 iota 的输出大小将是
because we'll just yeah I see what you're doing there so you're creating a std vector with default initialized ints. And then you figure out how many there are by taking the distance from the start of the equal range to the end of the equal range. And then that start should be s there. I'm not doing a great job of explaining this for the listener um but uh but yeah okay so i mean there's there's two things that you got to figure out here um which is how
因为我们将，是的，我明白你在那里的做法，所以你正在创建一个带有默认初始化 int 的 std vector。然后通过获取从 equal range 的起点到 equal range 的终点的距离来弄清楚有多少个。然后那个起点应该在那里是 s。我向听众解释这个做得不是很好，但是，但是，是的，好吧，我的意思是，这里有两件事你需要弄清楚，即
many um how many indices are you returning and you do that by computing the distance between the the iterator to the start of the equal range and the iterator to the end between the iterator to the start of the equal range and the iterator to the end of the equal range. And then you need to figure out what is the first indices index that you're returning. And you figure that out by computing the distance from the first iterator in the input
有多少，你要返回多少个索引，你通过计算指向 equal range 起点的迭代器与指向 equal range 起点的迭代器和指向 equal range 终点的迭代器之间的距离来做到这一点。然后你需要弄清楚你返回的第一个索引是什么。你通过计算从输入中的第一个迭代器
to the first iterator that matched the first iterator of the equal range. And then you create a vector of n elements, which is however many elements you've determined are in this equal range. And then you do a stood iota on that vector. And the initial value for the iota is the distance from that starting distance that you computed which was the distance from the beginning iterator to the input to the first iterator from the equal range yeah that made sense to me i'm not sure that anybody that's listening is gonna
到匹配 equal range 的第一个迭代器的第一个迭代器的距离来弄清楚这一点。然后你创建一个包含 n 个元素的 vector，这就是你在这个 equal range 中确定的元素数量。然后你对该 vector 执行一个 std iota。iota 的初始值是你计算出的那个起始距离，也就是从输入起始迭代器到 equal range 第一个迭代器的距离。是的，这对我来说说得通，我不确定听着的任何人都会
i mean i think it was pretty clear. You know, you sort. You stood range is sort. Then you stood range is equal range. Then you have to do a little sort of figuring out what is the index of the start of your equal range. And then you need to create a vector and then use IOTA to fill the indices using that sort of start. But do you really need to sort the entire thing? You don't need to sort it at all, technically. But, I mean, this is the direction I was hoping you'd go.
我的意思是，我觉得已经很清楚了。你知道的，你排序。你用 std ranges sort。然后你用 std ranges equal range。然后你必须做一点小小的计算来找出你的 equal range 起点的索引是什么。然后你需要创建一个 vector，然后使用 iota 使用该起点来填充索引。但是你真的需要对整个东西进行排序吗？从技术上讲，你根本不需要对它排序。但是，我的意思是，这就是我希望你走的方向。
Because it's, I mean, if you look at the input... Hey, in my defense, the first thing I said is, well, my intuition is to sort it, but I'm wondering if we don't have to do that. So when you tell me later that I don't need to actually sort this thing, I just want it on the record that my first gut reaction was i don't think we have to sort this yeah the reason that i don't think that we need to sort this and that it's inefficient to sort this is um you don't care about the order of the things after the the target index you don't
因为，我的意思是，如果你看一下输入……嘿，恕我直言，我说的第一件事是，我的直觉是排序，但我一直在想我们是否不必这样做。所以当你稍后告诉我我实际上不需要对这个东西进行排序时，我希望记录在案的是，我的第一直觉反应是我认为我们不必排序。是的，我不认为我们需要对这个进行排序并且对这个进行排序效率低下的原因是，你不在乎目标索引之后的东西的顺序，你甚至
even really care about the order before either. Right. That's that also is true. Right, right, right, right, right.
真的不在乎之前的顺序。没错。这也是真的。对，对，对，对，对。
All you care about, all you care about is how many are in each of those, those groups. Exactly. Exactly. So you can technically do this in linear time. But do we use partition here? I mean,
你真正在乎的，你真正在乎的是其中每个组中有多少个。完全正确。完全正确。所以你技术上可以用线性时间做到这一点。但我们这里用 partition 吗？我的意思是，
if I were going to solve it in the linear time method, I'd just do two count ifs. Count if less, count if equal. Then you've got your values that you need in order to use IOTA. Walk me through that. So here are your target values, too. Count if less than two is going to give you one. And then count if equal what bastard that's very clever
如果我要用线性时间的方法来解决它，我只会做两个 count if。小于的 count if，等于的 count if。然后你就有你需要的值来使用 iota。跟我过一遍这个。所以这里是你的目标值，2。小于 2 的 count if 会给你 1。然后等于的 count if，太棒了，这非常聪明，
and then count if equal gives you you're basically so so here in our solution that we're looking at we have n which is the number of equal elements and then start which is the distance between the equal range beginning of the equal range result of equal range and the start of the equal range, result of equal range, and the start of the array. You can get those two values by just doing countifs with lambdas, one that checks less than target value, one that checks equal to. However, I'm glad you went with the sort because we're going to hop over to BQN now, and we're looking at 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 lines. But you could code golf this.
然后等于的 count if 给你。你基本上，所以，所以在我们正在看的解决方案中，我们有 n，它等于相等元素的数量，然后有 start，它是 equal range 的起点与 equal range 结果的起点、equal range 结果与数组起点之间的距离。你可以通过使用带有 lambda 的 count if 来获得这两个值，一个检查小于目标值，一个检查等于目标值。然而，我很高兴你选择了排序，因为我们现在要跳转到 BQN，我们正在看 1、2、3、4、5、6、7 行代码。但你可以对这个进行代码高尔夫。
If we had access to like thrusts um uh counting iterator we could just we could reduce the last three lines into a single line with a range constructor and sort of creating this in place in a constructor instead of having a costed iota why aren't we why aren't we returning an iota view here um because the question asks you to turn a vector and those are not implicitly. The question is ill-formed. You can't do anything with views. The question meant to ask you to return a view or a range. That's true.
如果我们能够访问类似于 thrusts 的计数迭代器，我们就可以将最后三行简化为单行，使用范围构造函数并在构造函数中就地创建它，而不是使用开销重大的 iota。为什么我们不，为什么我们不在这里返回一个 iota view？因为问题要求你返回一个 vector，而那些不是隐式的。这个问题出问题了。你无法对 views 做任何事。这个问题本意是要求你返回一个 view 或一个 range。确实如此。
Let's see what happens if we go. We delete these last three lines, and we go return stood. Is it views or view? View iota and we're gonna go with start and start plus n and you said it was views but actually maybe that's because I'm not including the range header. Compiling, compiling and it looks like that is correct.
让我们看看如果我们这样做会发生什么。我们删除最后三行，然后我们输入 return std。是 views 还是 view？View iota，然后我们将使用 start 和 start plus n，你刚才说它是 views，但实际上也许那是因为我没有包含 ranges 头文件。编译中，编译中，看起来那是正确的。
So yeah, we've reduced it. If we loosen the restrictions of this to one, two, three, four, five lines of code, first one sort, second one is range is equal range. Then there's two stud distances to get n and start, and then we're returning a views iota using start and start plus n. So not too bad, five lines. Pretty nice in my opinion.
所以，是的，我们精简了它。如果我们把这个限制放宽到一、两、三、四、五行代码，第一行是 sort，第二行是 ranges equal range。然后有两个 std distance 来获取 n 和 start，然后我们使用 start 和 start plus n 返回一个 views iota。所以还不错，五行。依我看相当不错。
Sure, there's more performant code doing the linear stuff, but I like this solution quite a bit. And now let's go and do something similar in BQM. So let's hop over to our next-gen APL. Stay tuned for part two next week. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当然，做线性处理的代码性能更高，但我挺喜欢这个解决方案的。现在让我们去 BQN 中做类似的事情。所以让我们跳到我们的下一代 APL。敬请期待下周的第二部分。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。